I understand that you might know the
truth Rumble people you might know the
truth about the world
doesn't mean you're better than other
people
because you believe in God and you think
that only fans girls are demons right
that doesn't make you better than other
people who are enjoying life
hearing sneako complain about his
audience almost feels like I'm hearing
Shanika complain about how sneakers
always behaved and let's be honest the
red pill is uh is dying it's over
speaking of things that are stupid what
sneakro
what
sir we love everybody
I was not ready for that [__] in case
you're wondering what the average Seiko
fan looks like that [__] went that way
it went left wow
[Music]
at that age this guy's like 11 or 12
yelling [__] the women [__] the women
Andrew take
yeah yikes okay okay all right all right
yes sir we love everybody
[Applause]
it's just funny we I encounter fans all
the time
I don't think I've ever encountered
anyone below the age of 14 or Screaming
stuff no no anytime anyone's ever
approached us has always been very calm
and cordial very very common cordial
just imagining seeing my fans and that's
what they yelling you don't want to see
what his response was to like ah sure
they are children and obviously joking
this is how I was at 12. but if it
sounds egregious to you blame the
rainbow Flags in their classroom
blame the media for a masculating man no
no my God no
no my guy
oh my God
oh
it's your fault for forcing an obvious
agenda not these kids boys will be boys
you know what a lot of the audiences
these people Foster in regards to people
it's like a lot of this stuff were you
ever yell and [__] like that when you
was a kid
let's be let's be fair
I think the biggest I might remember is
watching rappers and y'all should get
money I didn't mean all I'm trying to
say is we think we also grew up with
media influences that weren't exactly
it's just he's a negative influence of
today yeah but even when you're growing
up that wears a lot of hip-hop artists
or whatever you was watching that were
sending some wrong messages and Kids was
listening simulate that stuff
I'm not gonna sit here and pretend like
rap music made a bunch of my homies
gentlemen when I was a kid no but I was
not necessarily repeating those stuff
maybe not individually but the people
around you you asking me I mean it
doesn't make what he's doing fine or
good now it's just recognizing that the
same way we had bad influences today a
lot of these red pill losers a lot of
the bad influences for young men today
it's funny because I remember when they
were trying to ban Andrew Tate
everywhere a lot of school teachers were
saying oh this is a negative influence
on my students the students are coming
in and saying all this stuff and I'm
like you gotta be exaggerating and then
you hear these kids going again
and I'm like oh
maybe those teachers weren't lying
there's a little bit of that whole him
completely like oh my God look at the
rainbow flag in the classrooms and all
the programs like Brett you're also
programming the kids too definitely
a hundred percent your flag is just a
woman being beaten up or being hated on
or being called stupid or [__] but you
got your own flags and these kids they
fly proudly they Sing the anthem without
even you asking exactly it's interesting
because they keep complaining about the
indoctrination of children
but you got you got a bunch of kids just
yelling your name randomly and repeating
a bunch of foul [__] that you've been
saying that's if that's not industration
you look at these kids oh my God look at
them yelling pronouns look at the kids
that you're fostering yelling how much
they hate the opposite gender and that
they think that gate should be merged
that's crazy wow programming
and if you ask these kids you wouldn't
even be able to tell you why so that's
where you see the programming when
you're just repeating some stuff you
don't know why you don't know where
that's from you don't know why you're
saying but you're saying it yep that's
programming right there yeah and let me
ask you when's the last time you've seen
one of these like purple head 12 year
olds talking about murking the straight
people but if you keep it in that stack
let me know when y'all heard that not
from adults I'm actually talking about
kids because that's what we saw on
screen we saw kids yelling that [__] I'm
all fine with people saying hey I don't
want this stuff in the classroom I don't
want all the lgbtq stuff in the
classroom okay that's fine but think
about where these kids are getting their
messaging IRL streaming is is what I
want to do now uh this is there's only
so long this you can only do this for so
long like how much can you really talk
about yeah data coach that's hilarious
uh yeah it's like it's just so much more
fun I can't even lie and let's be honest
the red pill is uh is dying it's over
it's over because like there was a lot
of hype around this like Oh The Matrix
bro how do we make it out and then like
you you there's this excitement I'm
fresh I'm fit I'm moisturized and
monetized I've said it before I'ma say
it again it's important to take care of
your skin because you know that's the
first thing that people see they see
your skin and they judge you on that
they don't want to say it but they
actually really do so we're gonna go
through that skincare routine together
right with the wonderful products of
teenage Italy so first thing that I do I
tie my hair yep I tie my hair because I
don't want to get my hair in the way
twice a week what I do is I take the
exfoliating scrub because I want to get
in the nooks and crannies all right I'll
go up there we always forget the edges
if it goes a little bit in my hair it's
okay it's not a Frog close your eyes
your face you're gonna use the clot
you have the daily face wash boom
[Music]
you're gonna put the under eye cream
before you moisturize that's what I do
you take the eye cream take one little
dab under your eyes like that takes away
the bags okay when I'm done with that I
take my morning facial everybody likes a
little facial in the morning pause
and just apply it like so so your face
is moisturized click on the link below
get your 30 off and a free gift yup and
get your skin care routine on
and I got it at the right time hit the
wave at the right time you know I was I
was red pill raging when the red pill
was blown up so it was perfect you know
scream at a camera oh my God
up and then now like okay you know live
life now can't be screaming at a camera
about saying every single day wow so
much maturity you've grown so much in
here this is why when so many people are
telling me like oh man he's my mentor
it's like this loser barely has his life
together doesn't have any of his own
opinions really solidify changes his
opinions every week one day he's a
Muslim the next day he's doing drugs and
threesomes the next day he's back to the
red pill the next day he's like red pill
stupid I'm done with it so if you can't
take goofballs like this seriously and
it's not even like a I said it before
it's just an age thing and people like
oh that's super dismissive like when
you're in your early 20s to mid 20s like
you're figuring [__] out you're trying
to latch on to ideas to feel comfortable
with yourself and the world around you
him switching up like this everyone's
like oh it's a grift he's a liar maybe
or maybe he's just a young man who's
realizing that life isn't what I thought
it was and that's normal for people who
get into adulthood and start taking on
responsibilities and taking on different
ideas that's it
that's it but the thing is do you want
to spend time listening to young people
ramble about [__] they barely understand
as if they were experts
me parsley
I'm too old for that [__] what about you
person the only reason I know these
people is because of you sure
way too old for this [__] okay like I'm
way if you're too old for this [__] yeah
I'm Geezer Geezer old yeah like but it's
all it's all good I understand it
because I understand it because I was at
that State like you say you say stuff
that you think you know with so much
like you're assertive about it and so
much
like I know because I know but you don't
know you don't know [__] and the more
you know the more you realize oh [__] I
don't know [__] about [__] it's funny
because my attitude now at 41 is more of
a there's a lot of [__] that I don't
know than when it when I was 20. when I
was 20 I was like well the thing is and
the Illuminati I don't know
now I'm just okay
okay I'm okay to say I don't know
there's no shame in my game there's only
so much you can say about the red pill
right get a girl with the low body count
don't watch porn go to the gym boom done
that's like you sum up most of like
instead of repeating it and that's when
you guys kind of get off on just seeing
people like owning it's like when you're
14 and you watch Ben Shapiro owns Libs
oh yeah yeah [__] that college girl
stupid
[__] it's like not even anything
improving about it's just uh WWE for
[__] nerd incels
and you're the Undertaker
facts a couple of times you died and you
risen from the death like yeah you
participate in that and you you were in
that you were one of the main characters
okay the story better bro
red pill would never die no of course it
will never die dummy but it's just a red
pill it's just the truth you know and
it's just
you know what's really not red pill
talking about the red pill all day long
Non-Stop
actually being red pill if you're
talking about truth is going and
enjoying life becoming better every
single day being around good people
having a good Circle enjoying the world
like that's the the best thing you could
it's so cringy just hearing this guy
repeat [__] to him repeat [__] I said to
him like a year ago it's just like oh
yeah that's what it is that's the truth
I was like so when I said it wasn't the
truth but now you're still playing red
pill you're just repeating what I said
oh now that life is about Community
surrounding yourself with good people
and enjoying yourself wow this is when
did you say that to them
we did the interview online yeah yeah
I'm gonna talk about family and all this
other stuff I was like bro I want to
just have 21 [__]
and now he's like family creation is the
most important thing in life
it's crazy watching someone flip flop in
a year like seven times and you just
realize
the dude tries to be a leader but he's
probably the most impressionable person
I've ever met every day his ideology
changes his vision of the world changes
and it's okay to change yeah it was like
you can be loud like I know what I'm
talking about right but you flipping
like pancakes I got you maple syrup and
everything it's funny how religious
attacks will always say that being gay
is bad the gayest thing you could do
with the internet because there's so
many possibilities is argue with other
nerds online about religion constantly
that's the gay that's gayer than being
at a gay pride parade well this book
this Trinity this is the Crusades so
you're gay
why are you gay like you're describing
what you did and P game
you're gonna probably go back to that
too
I don't think so why would he go back to
that I don't know he wants to make money
listen this guy just goes with a Transit
he said it he was on the red pill stuff
and it was popping now that he's dying
he's off of it this dude just follows
Trent Andrew take became Muslim this
loser becomes Muslim is he a real Muslim
of course not but the aesthetic and the
veal of religion feels good for him he
gets to go in all Islamic podcasts he
gets a lot of these new fans who also
have issues with women so it's just a
benefit these guys they'll just jump on
whatever the [__] wave is but then if
you appear behind the curtains you're
like are you actually living that life
that you're claiming he's like no
they're not right they're all
degenerates also
we got a Discord we got a Reddit we got
a couple side stitches if you check the
description you can get access so you
don't want to miss all the videos that
we got going on side Channel side
[__] whatever you want I don't care
we out of Reddit or we got a Discord we
got a couple of top [__]
okay hey yo links in the description
below go check them out otherwise we
also have a video editing contest we're
hiring an editor if you want to be part
of it go to and basically edit your own
video of I've been preach upload it to
tick tock right with the caption admin
Preach video contest I'm gonna check you
out we might hire you on full time
remote job let's go I thought I thought
we were on the same page and that's what
I realized my core audience might be
people that come here all the time if
you look at the comments with the video
I did a video with neon and Jason love
right we just got dinner making making
jokes up like that I was asking if he
repents I was asking about if he thinks
porn is bad for society I'm talking
about you know his religion stuff like
that I'm talking about everything that
you guys always obsess over about so
just you know make my community happy
right the comments on neon's VOD on his
YouTube channel compared to my comments
on my Roma channel the difference is
just insane
my Rumble Comics all that's like I was
hanging out with these two still gonna
betrayed us why is he eating dinner with
these people
you should be yelling at [__] with
Myron right now oh wait wait so so so
you watered grass now your grass grew
and now you're complaining about grass
that's facts you cultivated the most
hyper judgmental Audience by being hyper
judgmental everyone you would watch
videos call people dumb feminists all
this other stuff this that and the third
and then when you realize your audience
is exactly a reflection of who you are
and how you behave you want to cry about
it look at all this grass hey look at
all this grass in my yard and I've been
watering for six months talk to him and
then neon's comments
we love you so much neon keep going yeah
this was so funny great video You're
evolving every day if I just let like
the rumble audience you people dictate
everything that I do it would just well
it would go insane I would go insane
all NPCs on Kick bro like
I understand that you might know the
truth Rumble people you might know the
truth about the world
doesn't mean you're better than other
people because you believe in God and
you think that only fans girls are
demons right that doesn't make you
better than other people who are
enjoying life please
please
Doug hearing sneako complaining about
his audience almost feels like I'm
hearing schnego complaining about how
Snickers always behaved he always made
himself seem better for knowing the
truth he called everyone Bots for not
being red pill and knowing the truth he
always positions himself as being better
because he was plugged in in red pill
it's just it's crazy to say you know
when you probably know the truth but you
knowing that thing doesn't make you
better than anybody else all right
listen I told you I told y'all this
whole movement is dying
this whole movement is dying because the
people who are leading it are idiots
okay they're dumb people no business
strategy don't know how to navigate and
I don't understand the fact that despite
the rhetoric they don't own any Equity
they don't own these platforms see
platforms can literally delete their
whole movement in a minute and they will
and they already have the gun and this
whole red pill phase has just been dying
out and it's also repetitive like how
many times are you gonna debate can men
and women be friends how many times are
you going to debate whether or not a
woman's body count matters or whatever
financing got to make new topics Under
the Sun but at some point yelling about
the same [__] every day with different
boob jobs gets boring oh
it does
tell it like it is
different [__] same topic
that's what these panel of horse wow
two weird looking dudes
same topic
I'm not saying we're out here
groundbreaking or whatever but at least
we should be trying to have laughs and
just chill out like if you think I want
to cover trans women in sports again you
are [__] crazy like do I think it's
wrong absolutely do I want to cover that
topic every day perhaps a [__] lutely
not and listen y'all may not believe
this but whenever I meet trans people in
person like it's mad chilling cool like
I got no problem with them personally so
I don't want to be out here complaining
like I hate I don't I think this Topic's
stupid but I'm ready to move on and do
different things okay I'm just like yo
what's up that's it I don't care enough
these dudes like the the way the energy
like you know they gotta hate these
Rhymes that's crazy every day so it's
like women deserve less you're inferior
blah blah blah women are stupid sorry
holy [__] can you anything else anything
else you want to say
no I am baffled
thank you
rep will die
how do y'all feel about it it is I'm so
glad this Trends over I'm so glad this
trend's over I think it was poisoning a
lot of dudes I think there's definitely
some truth in the fact that there's
certain aspects of society disadvantage
men it's okay to have those
conversations but the way these people
are having the conversation evolved from
like oh man got issues to women should
lose the right to vote uh you know men
should be just giving a wife or start
building your Harem go abroad to find
your way like it's all like it was just
progressively just doing stuff that I'm
like what's all this overall
I think most of these dudes got exposed
to being losers who either paid for
product or didn't live the life that
they pretended so that's why the
movement is dead
you decide to see the red pill go no I
don't care you don't care I think in
real life it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter yeah because we walk around like
we're not seeing these red pill weirdos
no they literally just stay behind their
keyboards a little Discord Community
nobody knows they even [__] exist
really all the good clubs and watch
people in a corner dance look at this
[__]
you want some no [__] you there you were
ugly anyway
[__]
horse
bumps bumps bumps bumps
you're picking up the cash I gave you
why all these women picking up the cash
I gave them yes I'm in a super bar it
doesn't matter [__]
hahaha